so how does one really know if they're
deficient in bile
what is bile bile is a detergent okay it
helps you break down the fats that helps
you break them down and it helps you
extract the fat side of vitamins and
other essential fats like omega-3 fatty
acids without bile you can't pull those
into the body but bile does a lot more
than that
it helps keep your microbial balance in
check it helps keep the fat from
building up in the liver it helps remove
toxic waste through the body it helps
eliminate the excess of cholesterol that
your body doesn't need it even helps
lubricate the colon to allow food to go
through the body a lot easier so number
one if you're deficient you're gonna
usually be low in one of the fat soluble
vitamins so vitamin A there's a lot of
symptoms but one would be you can't see
in the dark too well you're driving you
can't see at night too well
vitamin D deficiency bone pain lowered
mood because one of the symptoms of
vitamin D is depression between lower
immune system it could be many different
things psoriasis is will be one and if
you're low in vitamin E which is the fat
side of a vitamin you might have dry
skin you may have hot flashes chest pain
but the big one is weak muscles because
without vitamin E you just don't have
the level of oxygen for the muscles to
work effectively and then vitamin k1
you'll get bruising vitamin k2 you can
have a lot of issues you could have
kidney stones you can have calcified
arteries you could have high blood
pressure from that you can even have
calcium deposits in your joints alright
number two
jaundice okay you start looking a little
yellow and the whites of the eye and
even the skin 3 is constipation
why because bio lubricates the colon now
if you have too much bile you get
diarrhea by the way and as a side note
if you have diarrhea you don't want to
take bowel cells because that'll make it
worse alright number four you could
develop a fatty liver if your bile
deficient also bloating because bile
helps you digest
fad so if you're getting undigested fat
stuff is gonna sit there longer and
you're gonna feel more bloated you might
burp and belch that's a sign of a
sluggish gallbladder all right number
six your stool floats why because you're
not digesting fat and the fat ends up in
your stool and it will flow or your
stool is light-colored you may develop
gall stones as a symptom of a bile
deficiency because bile is there to help
prevent gall stones now why would you be
deficient in the first place well maybe
you're on a low-fat diet
you're not consuming saturated fats that
are the stimulus to release bile or
let's say you have a fatty liver because
bile is made from your liver it's stored
in the gall butter but it's made from
the liver so if there's damage in the
liver either fatty liver it's inflamed
or you have cirrhosis that could be why
you're not producing the bile or let's
say you don't have a gall bladder it was
removed well you're gonna be bile
deficient in which case you need to take
some bile salts after the meal all right
no gut bacteria or a lesser amounts of
gut bacteria your bacteria is there to
help you recycle bile over 90 percent of
the bile in your body is recycled and
when you eat your body is very efficient
in recycling this bile over and over and
over to extract more and more of these
nutrients from the food that you're
eating so we really need this gut
bacteria for that or let's say you have
a damaged GI system where you have scar
tissue in the colon and guess what
that's going to create the lack of
absorption of bile salts so you don't
have that for recycling anymore because
only a little bit of it's getting
through so whether you have Crohn's or
irritable bowel syndrome or some past
damage with your GI tract that could
limit your bile in which case you might
need to substitute and take some vile to
achieve the right amounts all right guys
see in the next video
so if you're enjoying this content go
ahead and share it with someone that
could really benefit from it